the emergency room
of one of delhi's biggest hospitals
they're constantly having to move out
the dead
to make way for more and most of those
in this room
are dying and they haven't been admitted
yet to the hospital
the doctors are simply overwhelmed
scrambling for oxygen
and reduced to begging for help on
social media
india set a worldwide record nobody
wants for a second day running it topped
the number of global daily coronavirus
cases
they're shocked and ashamed at how the
country's healthcare system is all but
breaking
the weak and ill have spilled out onto
the pavement outside
and there's no dignity and death here
the final few breaths taken by this man
came after his brother had begged for
oxygen for him for six
hours some turned up barely
able to walk only to turn around
immediately
after being told they'd be better off
trying elsewhere
whilst this family brought their mother
but saw her die minutes after reaching
what they hoped was help
this hospital is useless she's shouting
but it's not isolated in its inability
to cope right now
only grief is here in abundance
distraught relatives found no beds
little oxygen few staff
and even less hope i have a message for
the government
please do something and please
release some oxygen supply people need
it here
people need beds here people need meds
here people need wards here
people need injections people need
medicines
and there are deep worries that the
figures could be even more alarmingly
high
with so many deaths unreported or
unlocked
the numbers of people who appear to be
very ill indeed
continues to build outside this hospital
and still none of them being admitted
which seems to indicate that if this is
happening to one of the biggest
hospitals in the capital what on earth
is happening
outside of the capital and almost
certainly there are more
added to these grim statistics with
every single
hour yesterday we came here with our
father
just here but no one came to see him he
just
saw didn't have to see me see when no
one came he died
and now i came
no one's seen him either all they can do
is wait and plead
if he's taken in and that's not
guaranteed he'll be immersed
into this one man told us there were
just seven
oxygen cylinders for 70 people
india is now home to the world's fastest
growing coronavirus crisis
with fears that the virus mutations
could be resistant to the vaccines
they seem unable to control it and
utterly unprepared to deal with it
alex crawford sky news delhi